Crisp Apple a handful of almonds and a
pint of blueberries all have one thing
in common
they've probably got here because of a
bee and according to researchers their
pollination is worth fifteen billion
dollars to the US Agriculture industry
each year but over the past decade bees
have been dying at an alarming rate and
nobody knows why so here's the situation
researchers began tracking bees in 2006
since then beekeepers have reported
losing an average of 30% of their bees
in the winters for a rough reference
beekeepers estimate that before 2007 the
rate was 15% what's more today
beekeepers are losing bees in the summer
when bee should be thriving in the past
two years
summer losses have been equal to or
greater than winter losses and annual
losses reach 44% in 2015 but what do
these losses actually affect let's take
a look at almonds California produces
80% of the world's almonds to pollinate
almond trees farmers rent bee hives 30%
of all hive rentals in the US go to
almond orchards from 1995 to 2010 the
price of hive rentals triple half of
that cost increase can be attributed to
the loss of bees environmentalists are
pointing the finger squarely on a class
of pesticides called neonicotinoids but
companies say the insecticides are
unfairly targeted and ensuing studies
have drawn conflicting conclusions one
thing scientists agree on however are
that multiple factors are stressing bees
out including chemical resistant
parasitic mites B viruses and poor
nutrition now here's the argument on one
side of the fence are those who oppose
pesticide restriction they say that the
loss of bees has not significantly
affected the price of food they argue
bans will reduce crop yields and point
to the European Union which recently
restricted some neonicotinoids in an
effort to save bees farmers in the UK
saw their rapeseed harvest fall 15% last
year
on the other side are those who see
industrial farming directly contributing
to the plight of the honeybee they
advocate for fewer pesticides and for
measures like more crop rotation to
improve bee nutrition and get colonies
back on track